welcome welcome to this video the
highlights video for then in the ninth
round of the candidates and before the
round we have a really funny standing
it's a roni anand anand leading on plus
2 followed by chronic on plus 1 and all
other players on minus 1 so there's
actually a really add some kind of young
line between the players we are we have
three players still in contention really
for the qualifying spot the first spot
and all other players are on minus one
and i really have bad chances so let's
start with the first game under Aikens
viddler two of the guys who are on a
minus score so Andre keen is actually
entering the open Sicilian and we have a
night off which is answered by the new
main line at 83 just a joke I don't
really think this will take over but but
it's a very popular move in this
tournament spitter place c5 and Bishop
b6 yeah instead of nine to be three
there's also 92 and he should be 6 plate
yeah this move has some in a way
preparing d5 under the right
circumstances and d5 is in fact not a
good news I've whitewood now play Bishop
e3 are also and four is an aggressive
tribe but it is a good move against
exactly here what and Drake in plate now
you play g4 and after that d5 is
perfectly acceptable for black in fact
if you look at the capture something
like that looks very comfortable for
black it's got a good central control
it's got this pawn on e5 and you can
easily develop and you can ask their
what exactly is G for doing
this position besides weakening your
your King side yeah just not great and
yeah well g5 that's probably what Dwight
needs to do and this now leads to hang
some exchanges white will get the porn
back and then endgame Queens trade it
yeah and in this end game if anybody has
something to do it's black because it
can actually attack this g5 porn get
this check this being played it turned
out though and I'm honest with you there
is not so much happening in this game it
turned out that black cannot do so much
to increase the pressure on this pawn
after a couple of news we at repetition
yeah and so on and well here and raking
play the rook she wanted after her
capture on g1 we had the game drawn um
it's important to note that they are not
allowed to agree a draw be formed 30 and
I guess this would have been the type of
game where like 25 years ago they would
have shaken hands a rafter that may be
because we're white has absolutely
nothing here awesome-ness even some
precision that he needs to to show not
much but a bit and we'll both players
are probably leaving their out of it and
just are content with the draw okay
let's not waste them any more time with
this the other games aren't interesting
enough um what's the next game to check
kayaking prom Nick coquina was winning
on his first game the round before this
long end game against Sevilla where
Kramnik is on plus one is mentioned but
looked a bit shaky against and Drake
indeed
God anywhere okay didn't really get
anywhere um okay what is kayaking doing
here actually he's a one-year four
player and now he's playing d4 Knight f3
yeah it it turns out that he actually is
playing the London system which is yeah
I deservedly rare guest at top
tournament chess simply because it's
yeah not considered to be aggressive
enough to put any pressure on black on
yeah it was meant as a surprise weapon
and in a way it it works to some extent
Kramnik now played the movie 6 which is
obviously not a mistake but I really
would have liked to know what kayaking
had prepared against the main move c5
which is for a long time believed to be
just give black very fine position like
it's just playing in a more more active
manner like that this is what I also had
recommended myself in a video i did on
this channel um about one and a half
years ago if you search for london on my
channel or chess explained london system
something like that you'll find it yeah
chronic didn't play that he played solid
but not so ambitious ambitiously was c6
and all this now looks fairly normal up
to queen bee three this actually has
been played a number of times the
position also quite often pops up with
the bishop on on f5 and Seto g4 it's
still a very similar type of structure
yeah what I think that black should do
is of course you need to cover b7 right
so let's say you take and play Queen B 6
yeah this looks like a normal way to
play and after and this for example we
get a position that has been played
number of times before where you can
argue if white has
something or if it's just equal this is
a typical way to play for black yeah
back to the position here Kramnik now
throat for a while and then came up with
the moose d takes e4 which never has
been played in this position and for
good reason to be honest yeah ki can
just boom just took on b7 and isn't this
terribly weak now it is and black cam
has no way to defend the pawns he took
on a three play tonight d5 yeah okay
white needs to retreat the bishop than
one triple bonds and here it turned out
that chronic initially planned move the
should be form is just failing due to
Bishop takes e4 as night XD three queen
before sir totally hopeless yeah well
this is what he had overlooked as he
later told in the press conference when
he took on c4 so what that means is
Bishop before it's not really making any
sense and while he played this move and
after Queen here it is very difficult
now to find any sort of compensation for
black your pawn down your whole Queen
side is shattered and white has the has
the bishop pair on top of all of that
yeah he tried to to play actively of
course but white could just grab
everything here check ya gave away the
spawn as well yeah black can try to to
cover here but this a 4d form is just a
dream position look at this and then a
five coming and it's just it's just
terrible yeah well he gave away this and
tried now to set up some sort of
blockade on the light squares but if you
do a simple body count von count
seven points five points nope never ever
you will have compensation for two
points and Kenya Kane is doing a good
job of converting this team just does
not give away any of the pawns and
slowly improves his position in the
somewhat later stages here he had wanted
to possibly quicker wins but it's just
completely enough what he did White has
the activity and end the material and
both us just too much yak winsome I
trade it now Black gets actually to
capture have three but they're still two
pawns yeah i'm going through this really
quickly now it was simply a very clean
technical performance by kayaking and
not so much to yet you can comment upon
the pawn is nicely supported from behind
and there is still something on the King
side so wyd can push champ at the end
wyd managed to set the spawns in motion
here the key point is that there's
always a route coming to the shack
ketchum ultimately led to win for
kayaking him so very important win for
him he's back on fifty percent well for
kramnik this is obviously a disaster he
was on +1 and stood somehow in the in
the mix of it the only real on persia of
the two leaders but if you look at
chrome Knicks games in this tournament
he really had a very shaky performance
II could have easily really easily lost
22 Mammadyarov and then we wouldn't even
he wouldn't even had this plus one score
and yesterday's game also was a ted
shaky yeah he's simply not in good form
and
here to take on c4 and blunder basically
the whole game with this move is really
shocking for four player of his
visibilities um cara lee cannot remember
him scene yeah being in a almost lost
position after ten moves against the
london system of all openings it's not
like he was some and i know he was
experimenting with the sicilian and
someone found super computer generated
sacrifice or something it's just like he
just blundered b7 basically by this by
this calculation error yeah the tool is
too many mistakes really to qualified so
it's back on fifty percent and kayaking
as well he's also on fifty percent now
and if you ask me kayaking has a slight
chance now to do something in the
tournament as crazy as it sounds but
he's him still play he will still play
he still play some Aronian and he's
still playing aren't so if in some way
he gets two wins from that you would
have really good chances okay I'm just
um I'm just saying that he has some
momentum now with two wins in a row
after this really dreadful start ok the
next game will be will be will be
mamedyarov aronia we got a new zone
something that you could expect him and
mum a jar of plays f3 very ambitious
line aiming at the full center which
aronia allows with castles this is a
ambitious line for black but interesting
we see that white gains lots of space in
the center but neglects his development
after f6 here um white basically must
take you cannot keep your center and
here we come to a very important point
we see that number gerroff already had
spent a couple of minutes to to get
there but Aronian obviously was still in
his preparation he had played all these
moves very quickly
and now came up with a with a really
interesting new idea the main luffy has
just Queen f6 check but he played
Queenie a check okay yeah what we need
to is the only way to to tackle that if
you interpose something else or black
just develops nicely and you have just
half your pieces clocked up Queenie 2 is
the ambitious move of course black does
not want to trade queens now giving
white the bishop and sort of end game he
played Queen f7 this was the whole point
of it to get the rook to e8 quickly yeah
this happened he was still playing crook
leaves black black has sacrificed two
pawns at the moment but he has very
concrete play threatening this fork and
going to the c-4 square yeah I think a
very good defense now from Mammadyarov
it's basically the only one to be honest
but so takes yeah tiem aronian could
have gotten the exchange back and play
this position maybe this was actually
the most precise way to do it it's still
a very very tricky and complicated
position where White has some celeste
those two pawns and while this is simply
a very funny set up on the the King side
if black ever takes the pawn he will
have been very insecure King with the
bishop possibly at some point can be 35
on the other hand white can easily try
to threaten with a troy h5 h6 to cover
it yeah aronian played the pawn capture
because he thought you will get the
exchange anyway and this is true we got
the exchange with 95 and we come to this
position yeah and white here has a very
simple plan he wants to push the h-bond
all the way to age 62 yeah make sure
that this pawn on g7 will be a major
pain yeah aronia tries for quick counter
play on the queenside
with B form I'm not sure if this really
was was helping him so much but this
position is very very tough to play and
complicated we see by now that Aronian
was the one was with less time on the
clock he probably felt that he maybe had
played with fire a bit too much here
with this opening experiment our
experiment is maybe the wrong what he
had prepared it but look at the position
look at blacks King it's it's not clear
to me how in the long run you're going
to play with this king with the porn on
age six supporting g7 yeah the item
after this white actually gained another
idea getting the long diagonal for the
bishop ya hear the position is already
lost it seems if you check it with an
engine it will give white a very very
decisive advantage already I still have
a hard time to really determine what the
error was maybe it was really before
this kind of push maybe was mistimed but
I couldn't I couldn't really solve this
problem what black should do here I
don't think he is sinning so terrible
shape but what actually answered what
you should play I very much would prefer
to be whitey I'm honest with you this is
clear but I'm not sure how bad it really
is that in the game it was it was a
disaster really with d5 look what what
happened I'm going through this quickly
but you'll get the idea now here white
now manages to exchange and well thick
black king this is simply the issue yeah
Queen threatens to to invade getting now
that's it it's just like two nails in
the coffin of blacks king and they're
very nice transformation out by
Mammadyarov Queen f7 prevents night h5
can play it anyway the Queen takes you
get check check mate it really quickly
okay so we treated here and yeah what
now very nice move now pombe dro
phonetic we do a check yeah calling it
the Queen sacrifices it's a bit much
here you get it back immediately and
well this funny porns decide the day why
just threatens 90 f6 and promotion and
this is what happened check he had had
another win to be honest but this is a
very technical and clean way to do it
why just goes to an opposite colored
bishop sent game why he has two extra
Paul's this quite often is not the end
of the world and well in opposite
colored bishop sent game but white has
so many potential passes that it's
simply too much and besides the fact two
points this is a double pond so it's a
it's an in effect almost like three
pawns yeah white is totally winning here
and Aronian resigned yeah of two hours I
think this may be this opening its
hindsight is always twenty-twenty yeah
he lost the game may open should have
done something else yeah to be honest i
really i like this concept it's just
very creative here with with this but
isn't this a bit too sharp I don't know
it feels like very much playing playing
along the strength of your opponent
Mammadyarov is just a very good player
in this in this complicated um and and
and only even type of dynamic positions
well aronia is also really great
strategical player and not saying he is
bad in complications don't get me wrong
but maybe I'm something less
massive was what's more suitable for
this game but okay afterwards you know
okay let's see one game left by this
year of course island to ball off let's
see what happened here and as I
mentioned before we have a new main line
of the night off here it is again h3
okay but again we see it leads to
interesting play if played correctly
yeah to pull off sets up a position that
is very much typical for the ravening
and variation or ravening um we can go
to this position here White has gained
lots of space on the King side of course
so any short castling ideas need to be
judged very carefully and I got here was
she playing b3 covering the important c
4 square here really the question is
what should black do um i personally
like the idea to play Queen a 522 to
irritate them quite a bit setting up
this threat yeah um the thing is that
this is not a good move due to d5 and
push it before so why probably needs to
go here and maybe now get out of this
discovery and just continue on let's
same f 497 Queenie to castles no rb5 and
I'm not sure b5 this and it looks like
it typically complicated Sicilian in
position to me without going into any
any details IAM the pile of played a
completely different approach which was
criticized by anand later in the press
conference he played an f5 young and i'm
not one hundred percent sure but i tend
to agree with the honor
was obviously knowing more about the
game than I do but yeah you can have
different opinions about positions and
this mean f5 accomplished one thing you
won't get this kind of race situation
where why does storming your king side
but on the other hand um after the
capture which is pretty much frost we
get to a position where these pawns are
ya a target for whites pieces this is
very comparable to some lines in the
French defense and as it turned out to
pallav didn't really find a setup where
you would get a good a good defensive
set up but also some counter play he
decided to to simplify the position like
that and try to defend this in this
manner but wyd always keep something
because black has so many pawns on light
squares your bishop is just most much
stronger we'll get to h3 check you don't
like like here and it will be a very
very uncomfortable defense for black it
still it's not like white is winning
it's just a position where um yeah we're
good player would like to be white
simply because you are the one to to
call the shots here yet to pull off now
place the move h6 as mentioned he's not
a very he's not very much a guy to
defend the position just by by staying
passive and waiting things or just
trying to find some sort of fortress he
always wants to defend actively and this
is such a move it infected backfires
terribly here could take now and queen
g-form this was played by or not and now
we see that this attack can only be
parried but this move h5 bishop moves
and a five and so white with Tempe yeah
sort of the natural flow managed to put
porn cm and this sir is really tricky
for black in the long run this is a very
important and annoying weakness and h6
is also weakness it is very difficult
even for black to play moves here what
are you doing if you move the Queen for
instance I'm coming right to have six
and win it's already if you give it to a
computer Plex lost plus two points
something and this is actually
controlled by the cause of the game what
should like do now move like that yeah
okay go here okay black get some running
out of moves in a way this exactly is
the game continuation you cannot move
the Queen you cannot move the king you
can only move your bishop and yeah well
he went to to where five you could also
go here but check why do we win this
also yeah we got to an end game here we
just Queens on the board and with white
having a totally dominating position
with as mentioned those two important
points fixing the weaknesses 'if I've is
the extra porn and the passer and this
is a dominating Queen yeah and ratio is
black fine tactical and technical player
so he didn't check allow any sort of
thing to happen yet check and after this
to palo resigned so to complete the
overview of this round it was a total
triumph for for Arnold with a win
against the bottle of his on plus three
now with a great score and yeah aronian
is some after this loss just on plus 1
which means is one point behind and he's
got the worst I break so aronian in
effect needs to if let's say we she
draws all the games for
argument's sake five rounds left he
draws all games not spectacular result
and this would mean that Aronian would
need to score three wins to catch him
and overtake him because the tiebreak is
in Alan's favor he has won the
individual game in round one so it's
this tournament already over yeah almost
almost but the thing is there are some
game still left of course that aren't
can can lose no doubt about that he will
face Kramnik with black always tough and
he will also face still face kayaking
who's on fifty percent and there's also
next round Mammadyarov was also on fifty
percent don't count this guy out his
winning games he can win games he's
shown that he lost three games but he
also won three games and he's a really
dangerous um yeah okay the tournament is
not over yet but it's getting very very
tough to catch on and plus free and he's
also by far the best player in this
tournament as as it in terms of the
quality of the play then they all have
lost two games by now and he hasn't lost
any and he wasn't even close in a game I
mean you probably if we could go through
all of them you've defined some spot
where where there was an improvement for
their opponent but it's not like he
could have lost a game like with one
move by the opposition and then that's
it so what can you do is playing a great
tournament and it's probably if he's
going to make it it's one of the really
the most sensational results I can
remember because he was completely out
of the picture for most for most of the
experts before I gave him a five percent
chance to to win this thing which is not
much so I gave him five percent ask
Grandmaster yeah melinski famous um
chess teacher and commentator about that
it gave vichy 0% chance to win okay
let's see what happens some in the next
rounds tomorrow as a rest day and will
commence with this tournament unknown
cheers dave and will certainly no more
of no more after this round okay thanks
for watching